in this video today we will discuss
about the presumed appearance of one of
the titans from king of the monsters
in this next movie godzilla vs kong yes
we are talking about behemoth the sloth
mahmud stein from the amazon jungle
this titan has become one of the most
loved of the new kaiju created by
legendary pictures
especially with a name that is commonly
used to describe something big
it was bound to have a lot of fan
following after the 2019 movie
so we will talk more about this titan in
depth and how it might appear in the
next flick due to leaked images slash
leaked plots or maybe they are just
teasing us who knows
but anyway we will see if he appears in
it
then whose side will he be on and if he
dies in it then
that's sad so let's do this thing
let's start with a description of this
titan behemoth resembles a prehistoric
ground sloth with a large curved tusk
resembling dose of a mammoth knuckle
walking in a way reminiscent of that of
a gorilla
he is covered in light brown fur while
his head resembles that of a mammoth
with small ears and a short taper-like
trunk behemoth also has a row of
serrated granite spines fortified with
metal and ore running down his back the
ends of his four limbs are tipped with
broad fingers
bearing very large claws like an ant
eater with his hind limbs being stouter
for weight bearing
due to this behemoth is capable of
standing on his hind limbs
and behemoth stars also appears to have
some sort of green algae or vines
growing on them
in king of the monsters behemoth is
contained and monitored in monarch
outpost number 58 in a cavern in rio
brazil
designated as titanos behemoth or also
known as
muppen gwari to the locals his files
briefly examined by mark russell in the
novelization
later behemoth is awakened by the call
of his new alpha ghidorah
and he along with the other titans
excluding godzilla mothra and kong
are sent to hun and destroy cities and
creating havoc wherever they go
behemoth himself ramps into buildings in
rio
demolishing them with dusk with ease
soon madison russell activates the orc
in boston leading to the battle between
godzilla
ghidorah mothra and rodan and behemoth
is one of the only few talents that are
able to make the journey
to boston seeing godzilla as the new
king of the monsters
the godzilla vs kong toy leaked images
teased the return of the skull crawler
alongside a new titan warbat
a hell hawk and another old one that is
behemoth
we were expecting at least one of the
titans from the previous three movies to
make a return
and we were not disappointed with the
leaks of course the murals were awesome
but they have been seen in the first
2014 movie
in godzilla aftershock and also in king
of the monsters so making them appear
again in this movie would just neglect
and leave out the other awesome ones
behind and out of
methuselah cellar and behemoth only the
last one
the behemoth would actually make for an
interesting side story that would
connect to the main arch
of the battle between godzilla and kong
so who will he side with will behemoth
sight would come as they are both
mammalian titans or
would he choose to side with godzilla
allowing for an interesting betrayal of
the species
since he already bowed down to the g-man
in the last film
michael doherty explained that behemoth
was supposed to actually have an
interesting
and cute backstory he imagined that
behemoth was capable of going by pedal
when necessary
allowing him to take swipe at an
opponent with his humongous claws
while normally he is a peaceful
herbivore grazing on plants
gigantic prehistoric trees with his herd
he was supposed to have massive gufs and
broken chains around his limbs
to him that he was once captured and
used as a war beast by some ancient
society
the cute part of the story is that
behemoth also likes belly rubs and being
groomed by
kong but obviously that would not happen
since behemoth is a very ancient titan
and gong as a young and growing one
so therefore the backstory had to change
anyway in the upcoming movie
there are a couple of theories that i
would like to put out for what would
happen to behemoth
and what his role in the movie is of
course it would be a small one but one
that would alter
the course of actions leading to a
battle between kong and godzilla
the first theory is that behemoth would
be seen traveling and reaching skull
island but due to the place becoming
unstable he would
meet his end along with the other
guidance that reached the place
it is of course confirmed that they are
all travelling there due to mysterious
circumstances and
it was seen in the end credit scenes of
kotm
the second theory is one that would be
more interesting than the first one
and this one involves the apex
organization and mecha godzilla
so the story might go like this behemoth
as was seen in the end credited scenes
of kotm
was back in the amazon reviving the
forest over there
apex activates mechagodzilla and they
engage in a fight and
ends up with behemoth dying godzilla
senses all of this
the dying behemoth and the biosignature
of ghidorah's brainwaves inside the new
mechanized titan
and that is why the g-man is on a hun
destroying facilities and military
installations all over the world
searching for mecha godzilla and in this
search he meets kong
and battles the giant ape as well as
seeing him as another potential threat
to not just to him but the other titles
as well
of course in the end mechagodzilla
appears and they team up and destroy the
mecca and blah blah blah they go on
their own separate ways
so what do you guys think there is a
leak of behemoth in the choice of
godzilla vs kong and since the next
movie must
be a bigger hit than the last ones
therefore new titans and old ones have
to make a comeback
what we lack is the plot for behemoth
and whether he is again
seen just as a titan on the monitor
screens of monarch or will it
have a bigger role to play put in your
thoughts in the comments section and
make them creative
anyway we have come to the end of the
video do like share and subscribe for
more
monsterverse content and smash that
notification bell for regular updates
till the next one take care fam